summerhall the word was fraught with
doom it ended at summerhall with
sorcery fire and grief the tragedy at
summerhall was a mysterious disaster
that happened 40 years before the main
story
of game of thrones it was a fire that
killed a king
and birthed a prince and is tied to
dragons
magic prophecy and the destiny of
westeros
so what happened at summerhall
a hundred years ago king daeron
targaryen peacefully unified
dawn with the rest of westeros to
celebrate he built a castle called
summerhall
near the borders of the reach stormlands
and dawn
it was a lightly fortified castle more
of a palace
used as a home for targaryen princes at
the time of the dunk and egg stories
deron's son micah and some of his family
lived there
and eventually maika's son aegon or egg
became king in his adventures with dunk
egg learned to respect
the small folk the peasants or common
people
and to care for the poor and weak so as
king egg made laws to help the small
folk
giving them new rights and protections
and limiting the power of the lords
many lords hated this and some rebelled
against him
so egg spent much of his reign fighting
rebellions
even egg's children were rebellious egg
and his wife
betha arranged marriages for their kids
that would help build alliances with
other powerful houses
but their sons refused these arranged
marriages
eggs eldest son and heir prince duncan
gave up his claim to the throne and
married a mysterious common woman
called jenny of oldstones egg's son
jaehaerys and daughter sheira
fell in love with each other and got
married they had two kids
aerys and rhaella who also married each
other
and had kids which is like super double
incest
that's where rhaegar viserys and
daenerys come from
egg's youngest son daeron was meant to
marry a young elena redwine
the queen of thorns but daeron refused
the marriage
and instead had a relationship with a
knight called sir jeremy
before they died together in a battle
since prince duncan broke a betrothal
with a baratheon his sister rael
married a baratheon instead which led to
the birth of robert baratheon who would
later
overthrow the targaryens so king egg
was frustrated with his disobedient
children and rebellious lords
and he also faced the threat of the
blackfyres
he defeated the fourth blackfyre
rebellion but a fifth rebellion loomed
with melis the monstrous and the nine
penny kings
gathering in the east all egg wanted was
to bring peace and prosperity
and justice to westeros but he couldn't
do it when everyone fought against him
and forced him to compromise egg came to
believe that the only way he could get
enough
power to bring justice to the realm was
with dragons
for the first hundred years of their
dynasty the targaryens could crush
any enemy with their dragons but after
the targaryen civil war the dance of the
dragons
the dragons went extinct and the
targaryens weren't as powerful
they still had dragon eggs and they
tried everything to make them hatch
king aegon iii got nine mages to work
spells over the eggs
balor the blessed prayed over their eggs
maesters poured over the eggs
egg's brother arion drank wildfire to
transform himself into a dragon
but they all failed every time the
targaryens tried to hatch dragons
they just made fools of themselves or
corpses
but still egg's brother daeron and his
uncle aerys
even daemon blackfyre ii all said that
dragons
would return they saw it in prophetic
dreams and
read of it in prophecy soon king
egg ii dreamed of dragons
he became obsessed with ancient valyrian
dragon law
sending people searching as far east as
asshai for lost books and knowledge
he was desperate for the power that he
believed could bring
peace to westeros and this dream of
dragons led
to the tragedy at summerhall the books
only give us tiny hints of what happened
but
here's what we know king egg gathered
his family together to celebrate the
pregnancy of his granddaughter raela
and there king egg performed some kind
of ritual
involving seven dragon eggs pyromancers
and wildfire the fire got out of control
and people died the books don't actually
say
who died but it's implied and the
official app confirms
that king egg his son duncan and his
kingsguard
dunk died in the fire raela survived and
as summerhall burned she gave birth to
prince rhaegar
the book hints that dunk saved people
from the fire before he died so
maybe dunk saved raela and rhaegar back
in the hedge night dunk thinks that the
realm
might need his foot one day so maybe he
kicks down a door to save the princess
then
goes back into the fire to save king egg
and
dies with him perhaps it sounds like
jenny of old stones may have died in the
fire and
possibly queen betha and egg sisters and
their families and eggs brothers
children
summerhall explains why there are so few
targaryens left in the story
this disaster wiped out a generation of
them
it was a catastrophe for the royal
family so
what caused this fire we know
king egg was trying to hatch dragons he
had seven dragon eggs and wildfire
so maybe he thought the eggs would hatch
if he put them in a really hot fire
which isn't a bad idea the targaryens
used to hatch their dragon eggs in the
fires of the volcanic
island dragonstone some said that the
eggs needed that heat to hatch
so maybe king egg was just cooking some
goods and things got out of hand
cause egg was using wildfire with the
pyromancers of the alchemists guild
and wildfire is super dangerous it can
easily get out of control
and any little mistake can bring
catastrophe
in book 2 we learned that the
pyromancers make wildfire in rooms
rigged with sand held above so if the
wildfire gets out of control the sand
falls down
and smothers the flame and kills any
people
inside and thing is in dunk and egg
dunk has a dream where he and egg are
suffocated
in sand so some fans think that this
sand system was set up at summerhall
and must have killed dunk and egg
whatever the details playing with fire
is dangerous
so maybe somehow was just a terrible
accident
but if that's true why all the secrecy
and mystery around somehow the survivors
would not speak of what happened and
this part of the world book
is blotted out by ink so we can't see
the details of what happened
what's the author hiding here there are
theories
that summerhall was not an accident that
death was part of the plan
because in this story human sacrifice
has magical power
only death can pay for life and a great
gift
requires great sacrifice like
daenerys tries putting her dragon eggs
in a fire
and that doesn't make them hatch they
hatch when she
burns miri mazdur and the body of karl
drogo in a big funeral bio with her
eggs that sacrifice hatches her dragons
because only death can pay for life
in book 2 melisandre tries to wake a
dragon by
burning a bastard son of king robert
she says only a king's blood can wake
the stone dragon by stone dragon she
seems to think she can transform the
stone dragon statues on dragonstone into
living dragons
but stone dragons can also refer to
dragon eggs that have petrified into
stone
over time the point is that we've twice
seen the idea that human sacrifice in a
fire can wake dragons
so maybe the fire at summerhall was a
sacrifice to hatch dragon eggs
and king egg deliberately burned people
since king's blood has special power to
wake dragons
king egg might have sacrificed himself
walking
into the fire like daenerys in book 5
melisandre wants to sacrifice a king and
then his son
so that both die kings to maximize the
magical power to wake a dragon
maybe king egg tried the same thing
burning himself
and then his son duncan nor since
duncan abdicated he could have tried to
burn jaehaerys instead
or maybe egg tried to sacrifice raela
and her unborn child
rhaegar as the ultimate terrible
sacrifice to wake the dragons
but dunk intervened and stopped him
we can only speculate about the details
but
given what we know about magic and
sacrifice and dragons
summerhall looks a lot like a magic
sacrifice to hatch dragons
the question is is egg the kind of
person who would burn
his family alive in the dunkin egg
stories egg is a
sweet kid he's not mad or cruel he only
occasionally gets a little angry and
targaryen-y
but being king changes people you have
to be ruthless to rule
when egg became king his brother aemon
told him that
it takes a man to rule an aegon
not an egg kill the boy within you
and let the man be born maybe at
summerhall
king egg became ruthless and tried to
kill the boy to let dragons be born
it's a similar story to stannis a king
with good intentions
who burns people alive as sacrifices
he argues that the sacrifice of one
child is worth it
if it saves the kingdom maybe king egg
thought the same thing
when stannis considers burning mance and
his baby to wake a dragon
aemon says there is power in a king's
blood and
better men than stannis have done worse
things than this
maybe aemon is talking about his brother
egg
a good man who did a terrible thing
sacrificing his family
to wake dragons for the realm but
what could have convinced egg that this
magic sacrifice would work
king egg's family was really into
prophecy
prince duncan's wife jenny of oldstones
brought a woodswitch to court
a dwarfish albino woman who was
connected to the magic of the old gods
we meet this witch 40 years later in the
main series where she's called
the ghost of high heart and she has
accurate visions of the future
for seeing the red wedding and joffrey's
poisoning before they happen
so this witch is legit she can see
the future and she was influential in
king eggs court
prince aerys and rhaella got married
because this witch said that the prince
that was promised or azor ahai
would be born of their line which means
that
daenerys or john might be the prophesied
heroes to save the world
from the white walkers maybe that's why
prince duncan abdicated the throne
so his nephew aerys and the lion of azor
ahai
would inherit the throne instead some
fans suspect that bloodraven also
connected to the old gods had
something to do with this so that's a
whole thing but we also know that egg's
brother
aemon and his uncle aerys were also
interested in prophecy
as well as daeron with his dragon dreams
and arion with his
delusions so just like your auntie who's
like a little bit
too into astrology king egg's family
were
heavily influenced by prophecies and
dreams of the future
so maybe egg did summerhall because he
or the ghost of high heart or daeron had
a prophetic dream
that dragons would hatch from fire at
summerhall
problem is relying on prophecy in this
story
is dangerous prophecy will bite your
prick off
every time many characters have dreams
of the future
especially targaryens and especially
dreams about
terrible destructive events like the
doom of illyrio
and the red wedding the ghost of high
heart daenerys
patchface even theon all have dreams and
visions of the red wedding before it
happens
but dreams of the future are often
symbolic
and abstract and often misinterpreted by
the dreamer
like melisandre constantly misinterprets
her visions to convince herself that
stannis is the prophesied hero
she once has a vision of alice karstark
and convinces herself
it's arya stark the visions are true but
she twists the meaning
to see what she wants to see
misinterpreting a dream like that can
lead to a character's downfall
like in the mystery night daemon dreams
of a hatching dragon
so he convinces himself that he'll get a
dragon and win the throne but
he misinterpreted the dream so daemon
fails
aemon says that his brothers egg daeron
and aerion were all
killed by their dreams of dragons
because
arion dreamed of transforming into a
dragon by drinking wildfire
daeron's dragon dreams drove him to
self-destructive drinking
maybe eggs dragon dreams killed him
because like daemon and melisandre he
misinterpreted his
visions and saw what he wanted to see
youtuber joe magician argues that egg
may have had visions of the future
of daenerys hatching dragons from fire
and somehow
was eggs attempt to recreate this dream
thinking that the vision was about
him because the sacrifices at summerhall
mirrored the sacrifices at daenerys's
fire
king egg parallels carl drogo because
carl
is symbolically like a king princess
raela targaryen mirrors princess
daenerys targaryen
and raela's baby rhaegar mirrors
daenerys's baby rhaego
who dies shortly before this funeral
pyre
the witch mirri mazdur mirrors the
woodswitch the ghost
of high heart so maybe through the
symbolic language of prophetic dreams
eggs saw
a king and a princess and a baby and a
witch burning on a fire
and saw dragons hatching from the ashes
he convinced himself
this was his destiny and tried to make
it happen
by burning himself and his family to
hatch dragons and save the realm
tragically misled by prophetic dreams
like so many
others before him joe magician
speculates that other targaryens might
have had the same dream of daenerys's
fire
mad king aerys tried to burn king's
landing in a great funeral pyre thinking
he would rise again as a dragon
which sounds a lot like daenerys rising
from her funeral pyre
with dragons arion might have had the
same dream to convince him
that fire would make him a dragon all
these targaryens destroyed themselves
thinking that fire would give them
dragons
maybe they all dreamed of daenerys and
convinced themselves it was their
destiny
because the rebirth of dragons is a
powerfully significant magical event
so just like the doom of valyria and the
red wedding
and euron greyjoy's coming apocalypse
it sent shockwaves through time ripples
in the dreamscape
bringing prophetic visions to sensitive
individuals
and causing generations of targaryen
madness
and fiery catastrophe that's one theory
anyway we don't know if king egg had
visions of the future
we don't even know for sure if he
deliberately sacrificed people
but whatever he did to hatch dragons it
failed
and house targaryen was left weaker than
before
egg's sickly second son jaehaerys
inherited the throne
then came aerys who was mad possibly
because
of the fire and trauma of somerhole and
then the targaryens were overthrown in
robert's rebellion
so was summerhall just a giant
meaningless fuck-up that led to the end
of the targaryens
or did this death and disaster birth
some hope in dunk and egg
eggs brother daerong has a dream of a
dragon dying
but in the end it's not a literal dragon
that dies
it's a metaphorical dragon ball
targaryen
then in the mystery night daemon
blackfyre has a dream that a dragon will
hatch from an
egg but in the end it's not a literal
dragon that hatches it's a metaphor for
egg becoming a more confident targaryen
prince so in prophetic dreams a dragon
doesn't always mean a literal dragon it
can mean a targaryen
and in the same way the fire at
summerhall didn't hatch
a literal dragon but it did lead to the
birth of
rhaegar targaryen who is sometimes
called a dragon
so in a way king egg succeeded in
hatching a dragon at summerhall
just not the kind of dragon he expected
author george martin says that he likes
prophecies to come true
but in an unexpected way and even though
summerhall was a disaster that sacrifice
at the birth of rhaegar
might have set events in motion for
westeros to be
saved because like his ancestors rhaegar
was very
into prophecy at one point he and aemon
believed that rhaegar was the prince
that was promised or azor ahai
because the hero is prophesied to be
reborn
amidst smoke and salt aemon said that
the smoke was from the fire at
summerhall
and the salt was from the tears shared
for the people who died there
so maybe the tragedy at summerhall
fulfilled the prophecy to
make rhaegar the hero who'll save the
world
of course rhaegar did not save the world
he got
hammered by robert baratheon but rhaegar
did
probably father jon snow who along with
daenerys
probably will be the heroes who'll save
the world from the white walkers
by some interpretations rhaegar was the
hero azor ahai
but jon and daenerys and her dragons are
lightbringer the fiery sword that will
defeat the
darkness forged by sacrifice
so the prophecy works out the tragedy at
summerhall might have been a necessary
sacrifice
to birth the heroes who'll save westeros
death did pay for life though the price
was terrible rhaegar was haunted by the
tragedy of summerhall
he was born in grief and that shadow
hung over him
all his days he would go alone to the
ruins of summerhall
his birthplace and write sad songs of
sorrow
and death some fans speculate that he
may have met the ghost of high heart
at summerhall and sang her songs in
return for
prophetic visions cause in book three
the ghost
wants music in return for her dreams and
she always
asks for the same song jenny's song
that sad longing song that podrick sings
in the tv show
the song is about the ghost's friend
jenny of oldstones
and she weeps as she listens she says
she
gorged on grief at summerhall if the
ghost's prophecies are what convinced
egg to burn summerhall
maybe the ghost feels guilt as well as
grief
some fans speculate that rhaegar wrote
jenny's song
for the ghost of iheart rhaegar seemed
to share
that same sense of sadness and doom
maybe he understood that the tragedy at
summerhall was a sacrifice
a terrible price to pay for life in
westeros
there are other theories about
summerhall like maybe there was a
conspiracy
and some other faction caused the
disaster after all
king egg had many powerful enemies
like all the lords who hated his laws
who viewed him as a bloody handed
tyrant maybe those lords chucked some
extra wildfire into the mix to kill
king egg in book four mullen the mage
says that the maesters have a conspiracy
against magic
targaryens and dragons he claims that
the maesters somehow caused the
extinction of the dragons in the first
place
we know that the maesters poured over
the remaining dragon eggs
maybe they poisoned the eggs to stop
them from hatching
then when king egg tried to bring back
the dragons maybe the maesters made sure
it failed and tried to blow up the
targaryens once and for all
the grand maester at the time was a
young pycelle
and we know he's not trustworthy he
betrayed mad king aerys he betrayed
jon arryn maybe he betrayed king egg too
also at the time a young tywin lannister
was a cup-bearer to king egg
and tywin would have hated eggs
pro-peasant laws as much as anyone
and pycelle is loyal to taiwan so maybe
these guys worked together to make sure
the summer whole fire killed egg
a cheeky bit of ragicide to kick off
their lifelong alliance
and maybe a young mad aerys was in on it
he and tywin were childhood friends and
king egg's death did move aries closer
to inheriting the throne
each one of this trio of villainous
teenagers had potential motives to kill
egg
and they were all in the king's inner
circle
maybe they worked together to cause
somehow
or maybe the faceless men did it it's
hinted that the faceless men
caused the fiery doom of valyria which
killed most of the dragonlords 400 years
ago
maybe they also caused the fiery
summerhall which killed most of the
targaryens to prevent the return of the
dragons
the faceless men are master assassins
who take
great care to make their killings look
like natural deaths
maybe the faceless men used the
summerhall fire to hide their murder
maybe the faceless men were hired by
melees blackfyre and the ninepenny kings
they wanted king egg's throne and they
certainly didn't want him to get dragons
or maybe bloodraven did it working with
the ghost of high heart
they are both connected to the magic of
the old gods
maybe bloodraven sent the ghost her
prophetic dreams and made summerhall
happen cause he wanted a sacrifice to
make rhaegar azor ahai
or because he wanted to ensure that the
line of azor ahai would inherit the
throne
bloodraven has repeatedly shown that
he's willing to kill his relatives for
the sake of the targaryen bloodline
maybe bloodraven's lover shiera sea star
sparked the fire
and now she wears the mask of quaithe to
hide her arson-burned face
or maybe it was daario disguised as sir
pounce with a book of matches and a can
of gasoline
we can speculate all day there's lots of
possibilities for elaborate conspiracies
but
there's little evidence in the books
somehow is the end of the story of dunk
and egg
it might be the final novella in their
series
so you'd think that the tragedy at
summerhall will be about
their character arcs their choices
author george martin writes about the
human heart in conflict with itself
like jon snow's conflict between his
love for egret
and his duty to the watch george martin
loves this kind of
tragic heart-wrenching drama and you can
imagine something similar
at summerhall like egg would be
conflicted between his love for his
family and the need for sacrifice to
wake dragons for the realm and
dunk would be conflicted between his
loyalty to egg
and his duty as a knight to protect the
innocent
they could have a dramatic confrontation
amidst the flames of summerhall
the two friends divided in the end like
frodo
and sam on mount doom with dunk
desperately trying to stop
egg from sacrificing innocent lives to
the fire
maybe in the end dunk has to kill egg
to stop the burning like jaime and aerys
years later
that kind of personal drama at
summerhall could give a fitting
and emotionally devastating end to the
tales of dunk and
egg while making the tragedy really
about
a maester conspiracy or the faceless men
instead
might undermine the personal emotional
climax of dunk and eggs story
ultimately dragons and magic are a
metaphor for power
and ambition and the dangers of power
and ambition
like icarus flying to the sun too much
ambition can get you burned
and cause your downfall and that's what
the targaryens are all about
their ambition and power lust forged the
seven kingdoms into a united realm
but they also burned thousands of people
in wars and disasters and
madness summer hall is a warning against
the dangers of
power ambition and dreams showing how
even a good king like egg or stannis or
daenerys with the best intentions
can ultimately tragically end in
atrocity
fire can be the power to do great things
but too much light can hurt the eyes
and fire burns
king egg searched the world for
knowledge on valyrian dragon breeding
but we don't have to go to asshai
because we can learn knowledge and
skills
on skillshare skillshare is an online
learning site with thousands of classes
in
art design business and even cooking
eggs
with fire no human sacrifice required
there's even classes by kurzgesagt on
video editing in after effects which is
what we use
there's some really good stuff here and
the first thousand people to click the
link below
can get a free trial of skillshare
premium after the trial it's less than
10 bucks a month
for access to all of these classes so
learn something new
and help alt shift x by trying
skillshare at the link below
thanks for watching links to the artists
and references are below
thanks to the patrons cami hunt kyle lim
mario incandenza
at serdo blake dale ashik ishtiak harith
mutana alcurtis
and bambus lock cheers
if nothing else the tragedy of
summerhall is a good example of why you
should never bring high explosives to a
baby shower